let's see if we can find the limit as x
approaches negative one of x plus one
over the square root of x plus five
minus two
so our first reaction might just be okay
well let's just use our limit properties
a little bit this is going to be the
same thing as the limit as x approaches
negative one of x plus one
over
the limit
the
limit as x approaches negative 1 of
square root of x plus 5
minus 2.
and then we could say all right this
thing up here x plus 1 if this is if we
think about the graph y equals x plus 1
it's continuous everywhere especially at
x equals negative 1. and so to evaluate
this limit we just have to evaluate this
expression at x equals negative 1. so
this numerator is just going to evaluate
to negative 1 plus 1.
and then our denominator square root of
x plus 5 minus 2 isn't continuous
everywhere but it is continuous at x
equals negative 1. and so we can do the
same thing we can just substitute
negative 1 for x so this is going to be
the square root of negative one plus
five
minus two now what does this evaluate to
well in the numerator we get a zero and
in the denominator negative one plus
five is four take the principal root is
two minus two we get zero again so we
get
we got
over 0.
now when you see that you might be
tempted to give up you see oh look i'm
there's a 0 in the denominator maybe
this limit doesn't exist maybe i'm done
here what do i do
and if this was non-zero up here in the
numerator if you're taking a non-zero
value and dividing it by zero that is
undefined and your limit would not exist
but when you have zero over zero this is
indeterminate form and it doesn't mean
necessarily that your limit does not
exist and as we'll see in this video in
many futures one there are many future
ones there are tools at our disposal to
address this and we will look at one of
them
now the tool that we're going to look at
is is there another way of rewriting
this expression so that we can evaluate
its limit
without getting the zero over zero
well let's just rewrite
let's just take this
let me give it so let's take this thing
right over here and let's say this is g
of x so essentially what we're trying to
do is find the limit of g of x as x
approaches negative one
so we could write g of x
is equal to
x plus one and the whole reason why i'm
defining it as g of x is just to be able
to think of it more clearly as a
function and manipulate the function and
then think about similar functions
over x plus 5
minus 2 or x plus 1 over the square root
of x plus 5 minus 2.
now the technique we're going to use is
when you get this indeterminate form and
if you have a square root in either the
numerator or denominator it might help
to get rid of that square root and this
is often called rationalizing expression
in this case you have a square root in
the denominator so it would be
rationalizing
the denominator
and so this would be the way we would do
it is we'd be leveraging our knowledge
of difference of squares we know
we know that a plus b
times a minus b is equal to a squared
minus b squared you learned that in
algebra a little while ago or if we had
the square root of a
plus b
and we were to multiply that times the
square root of a minus b well that'd be
the square root of a squared which is
just going to be a minus b squared
so we can just leverage this these ideas
to get rid of this radical down here the
way we're going to do it is we're going
to multiply the numerator and
denominator by the square root of x plus
plus 2 right we have the minus 2 so we
multiply it times the plus 2.
so let's do that
so we have square root of x plus 5
plus
and we're going to multiply the
numerator times the same thing because
we don't want to change the value of the
expression this is 1.
so if we take the expression divided by
the same expression it's going to be 1.
so this is so square root of x 5 plus 2.
and so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to x plus 1
times the square root
times the square root of x plus 5
plus 2
and then the denominator is going to be
well it's going to be x the square root
of x plus 5 squared
which would be just x plus 5
and then minus 2 squared minus 4.
and so this down here simplifies to x
plus 5 minus 4 is just x plus 1.
so this is just
this is just x
plus 1. and it probably jumps out at you
that both the numerator and the
denominator have an x plus 1 in it so
maybe we can simplify so we could
simplify and just say well g of x is
equal to the square root of
x plus 5
plus 2.
now some of you might be feeling a
little off here and you would be correct
your spider senses would be say is this
is this definitely the same thing as
what we originally had before we
cancelled out the x plus ones and the
answer is the way i just wrote it it is
not the exact same thing it is the exact
same thing everywhere except at x equals
negative 1. this thing right over here
is defined at x equals negative 1. this
thing right over here is not defined at
x equals negative 1 and g of x was not
was not so g of x right over here you
don't get a good result when you try x
equals negative one and so in order for
this to truly be the same thing as g of
x the same function we have to say for
x not equal to negative one
now this is a simplified version of g of
x it is the same thing for any of input
x that g of x is defined this is going
to give you the same output and this has
the exact same domain now now that we've
put this constraint in as g of x
now you might say okay well how does
this help us because we want to find the
limit as x approaches negative one and
even here i had to put this little
constraint here that x cannot be equal
to negative one how do we think about
this limit well lucky for us we know
lucky for us we know that if we just
take another function f of x
if we say f of x is equal to the square
root of x plus 5
plus 2
well then we know that f of x
is equal to g of x
for
all
x not equal to negative 1 because f of x
does not have that constraint
and we know if this is true of 2 if this
is true of two functions
then the limit as x approaches
the limit let me write this down
since we know this because of this we
know that the limit
of f of x
as x approaches negative one is going to
be equal to the limit
of g of x
as x approaches negative one and this of
course is what we want to figure out
what was the beginning of the problem
and but we can now use f of x here
because only at x equals negative 1 that
they are not the same and if you were to
graph g of x it just has a it has a
point discontinuity or removable
discontent or i should just say a yeah
a point discontinuity right over here at
x equals negative
one
and so what is the limit
and we are in the home stretch now what
is the limit
of f of x or we could say the limit of
the square root of x plus 5
plus 2
as x approaches negative 1.
well this expression is continuous it or
this function is continuous at x equals
negative one so we can just evaluate it
at x equals negative one so this is
going to be the square root of negative
one plus five
plus two
so this is 4 square principle root of 4
is 2 2 plus 2 is equal to 4.
so since the limit of f of x as x
approaches negative 1 is 4 the limit of
g of x as x approaches negative 1 is
also
for and if this little this little
i guess you could say
leap that i just made right over here
doesn't make sense to you think about it
think about it visually
think about it
visually
so if this is
my
y-axis
and this is
my
x-axis
g of x
looked something like this
g of x let me draw it
g of x
looked something
something like
this
and it had a gap at negative 1.
so it had a gap right over there
while f of x
f of x would have the same graph except
it wouldn't have
it wouldn't have the gap and so if
you're trying to find the limit it seems
completely reasonable well let's just
use f of x and evaluate what f x would
be to kind of fill that gap at x equals
negative 1. so hopefully this graphical
version helps a little bit or if it
confuses you ignore it